The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well hello, everyone.
And welcome back to
Computational Systems Biology.
I am David Gifford and I
am delighted to be back
with you today.
We're going to talk,
today, about understanding
transcription.
Specifically, how we're going
to understand transcription
is a technique called RNA-seq.
And RNA-seq is a methodology
for characterizing RNA molecules
through next
generation sequencing.
And we'll talk, first,
about RNA-seq principles.
We'll then talk
about how to take
the data we learn from RNA-seq
and analyze it using tools
for characterizing
differential gene
expression and principal
component analysis.
And finally, we'll talk about
single cell RNA-seq, which
is a very important and growing
area of scientific inquiry.
But first, let's
talk about RNA-seq.
How many people have
heard of RNA-seq before?
Fantastic.
How many people
have done it before?
Some?
Great.
So RNA-seq is fairly
simple in concept.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to isolate RNA species from
a cell or collection of cells
in the desired condition.
And note that we can choose
which kind of RNA molecules
to isolate.
We can isolate molecules
before any selection, which
would include molecules that
are precursor RNAs that have not
been spliced yet,
including non-coding RNAs.
As you probably know, the
study of non-coding RNAs
is extraordinarily important.
There are over 3,300
so-called long non-coding RNAs
that have been
characterized so far.
Those are non-coding
RNAs over 200 bases long.
We'll be talking about
those later on, when
we talk about chromatin
function in the genome.
And of course, there are
the precursor messenger RNAs
that are spliced, turned into
messenger RNAs that are then
translated into protein.
And the specifics of
the RNA-seq protocol
will give you various
of these species
depending upon what kinds of
purification methodologies
you use.
But as you're aware,
there are many isoforms
that are possible in
most mammalian genes.
This is a short summary,
produced by the Burge
Laboratory, of different
kinds of splicing
events that can occur.
And the splicing
events are often
regulated by
cis-regulatory sequences
that live in the introns.
And these introns contain
recognition sequences
for splicing factors where
the splicing factors can
be conditionally expressed.
And so you get
different combinations
of these exons
being glued together
to produce variant
forms of proteins.
So we have to be
mindful of the idea
that the RNA
molecules that we're
going to be
observing, typically,
are going to be
reverse transcribed.
So we'll see entire
transcripts that came, perhaps,
from distinct exonic
locations in the genome.
And the essential
idea of RNA-seq
is that we take the RNA
molecules we care about--
in this case, we're
going to purify
the ones that have poly-A tails.
We will take those molecules.
We'll reverse transcribe them.
We'll sequence fragments
of them and then
map them to the genome.
Now if you don't purify
for poly-A tails,
you get a lot of things
mapping to the genome that
are intronic.
And so you get a
lot of data that
is very difficult to analyze.
So typically,
people, when they're
looking for gene
expression data,
will do poly-A purification.
And when you do this-- when you
sequence the result of doing
the reverse transcription
of these RNA molecules--
and you map the results to
the genome, what you find
is data that looks like this.
This is the SOX2 gene.
This is typical expression data.
You can see all of the
individual reads mapping
to the genome, the blue
in the plus strand,
the pink on the minus strand.
And our job is to take data
like this and to analyze it.
Now we can take
these data and we
can summarize them
in various formats.
One way is to simply
count the number of times
that we see a read
at a particular base,
like here, for the SMUG1 gene.
And here you see
something else going on,
which is that we have
reads from-- the sequencing
experiments have been
polyadenylated and purified.
So we're only seeing
the reads that
occur over the exonic
sequences, more or less.
There are a few intronic
reads there, scattered about.
The other thing that we see,
which is very important,
is that we see reads that
are split across exons.
Because the splicing
event has occurred,
the RNA molecule is
a contiguous sequence
of a collection of exons.
And sometimes you'll
get a read that
spans an exon-exon boundary.
And when we get
this, you can see,
in the bottom part of the
slide that I'm showing you,
these reads can map
across the exons.
Typically, in order to
get good performance out
of something like
this, we want to use
reads that are about
100 bases long.
And we'll use a mapper
that is capable of mapping
both ends of a read to
account for split reads
for these exon crossing events.
So that gives you an idea of
the kinds of data that we have.
And part of the
challenge now is looking
at how we can determine which
particular isoforms of a gene
are being expressed by
evaluating these data.
So there are two principal
ways of going about this.
One way is we simply
take our read data,
and we use the ideas
that we talked about
in genome assembly, and
we assemble the reads
into transcripts.
That's typically done de novo.
There are reference
guided assemblers.
It has the benefit that you
don't need a reference genome.
So sometimes, when you're
working with an organism that
does not have a well
characterized reference genome,
you will de novo
assemble the transcripts
from an RNA-seq experiment.
But it also has problems
with correctness,
as we saw when we
talked about assembly.
The other approach, which
is more typically used,
is to map reads, or aligned the
reads, to a reference genome
and identify the
different isoforms that
are being expressed
using constraints.
And ultimately, the goals
is to identify the isoforms
and quantitate them so we can
do further downstream analysis.
And you'll hear about
two different metrics,
sometimes, in the
literature, for expression.
One is the number of
reads per kilobase
of transcript per million reads.
So you might have, for
example, an RPKM metric
of 1,000, which means that one
out of every thousandth read
is mapping to a particular gene.
So it gives you a metric
that's adjusted for the fact
that longer genes will
produce more reads.
An alternative
metric is fragments
per kilobase per million.
And that's sometimes
used when we're
talking about paired end data.
And you're considering
that you're
sequencing both
ends of a fragment.
So here we're talking
about how many fragments
we see for a particular
gene per 1,000
bases of the gene per
million fragments.
OK.
So the essential idea,
then, is to take the reads
that we have-- the basket of
reads-- align it to the genome,
both to exons and
to exon crossings,
and to determine, for a given
gene, what isoforms we have
and how they're being expressed.
So from here on in,
I'm going to assume
that we're talking about
a gene and its isoforms.
And that's OK.
Because typically, we can
map reads uniquely to a gene.
And there are
details, of course,
when you have genes
there are paralogs that
have identical sequences across
the genome where this becomes
more difficult.
So if we consider
this, once again,
we're going to take
our reads, we're
going to map them to
the genome, and we're
going to look for all
possible pairings of exons.
What we would like
to do is to enumerate
all of the possible
isoforms that are possible
given the data that we have.
And we can use junction crossing
reads and other methodologies
to enumerate all the
possible isoforms.
But what we're
going to assume is
that we've enumerated
all the isoforms.
And we're going to
number them 1 through n.
So we have isoform 1, isoform
2, isoform 3 for a given gene.
And what we want to
compute for each isoform is
its relative contribution
to the read population
we're seeing that
maps to that gene.
So in order to do
that, what we could do
is use some constraints.
So if I show you
this picture, which
suggests that we have
possible splice events here
for the event C in the
middle, if I told you
that A, C, and E were very
highly covered by reeds,
you might think that
A, C, and E represented
one isoform that was
highly expressed.
And so if we think about
how to use our read
coverage as a guide to
determining isoform prevalence,
we'll be in good shape.
And really, that's the
best evidence we have.
We have two sources
of evidence, right?
We have our junction
crossing reads, which tell us
which exons are being
spliced together,
that helps us both compute
the set of possible isoforms
and estimate their prevalence.
The other thing we
have is the reads
that actually
simply cover exons.
And their relative
prevalence can also
help us compute the relative
amounts of different isoforms.
So in order to do this, we can
think about what reads tell us.
And some reads will
exclude certain isoforms.
So if we consider the
reads that we have,
we can think about reads that
cross particular junctions that
are inclusion reads
saying that-- for example,
in this case, the top
reads are indicating
that the middle white exon is
being included in a transcript
whereas the bottom
reads are exclusion
reads indicating that that
white exon in the middle
is being spliced out.
So what we would
like to do, then,
is to build a
probabilistic model that
takes into account what we know
about what a read tells us.
Because each read is
a piece of evidence.
And we're going to use
that read like detectives.
We're going to go in and
we're going to try and analyze
all of the different
reads we see for a gene
and use it to
weight what we think
is happening with
the different isoform
expressions in the pool of
reads that we're observing.
And in order to do
so, we will have
to build a function
that describes
the probability of
seeing a read given
the expression of a
particular isoform.
So the essential idea is this--
for the next three slides,
I want to build a model of
the probability of seeing
a read conditioned upon a
particular isoform being
expressed.
All right?
So there are three
ways to approach this.
One is that I can
see a read that I
know is incompatible
with a given isoform.
And therefore, the
probability of seeing that
read given the isoform is 0.
And that's perfectly fine.
And this can either happen
with a single ended read
or with a paired end read.
And it's a conditional
probability.
So the probability of seeing
read i given and isoform j
can be 0.
Another possibility is that,
if I have a transcript--
now recall that the
transcript has been spliced.
So what we're looking at
is the entire sequence
of the spliced isoform.
And we see a read.
And the read can land anywhere
within that transcript.
Let's assume, for
the time being,
we're looking at
single ended read.
Then, the probability
of seeing that read
land in that transcript
is 1 over the length
of the transcript-- all
right-- at a particular base.
So this read is compatible
with that transcript.
And we can describe the
probability in this fashion.
It's also possible for us to
consider paired end reads.
And if we have
paired end reads, we
can describe a
probability function
that has two
essential components.
The denominator
is still the same.
That is, the likelihood
of the read aligning
at a particular
position is going
to be 1 over the length
of the entire transcript.
The numerator is
different though.
We're going to compute
the length of the read
that we have, or the implied
length of the paired end read,
and ask, what's the
likelihood of seeing that.
So we don't know the exact
length, recall, of the insert.
When we're looking
at paired end reads,
we can only estimate
how long the fragment
is that we're sequencing.
And so we are going to have a
probabilistic interpretation
of how long the piece of RNA
is that we actually wound up
sequencing the ends of.
And that is placed
in the numerator,
which scales the 1 over l sub j.
So this gives us a
probability for seeing
a read in a particular
transcript that
accounts for the
fact that we have
to back both ends
to that transcript.
OK?
So we have three possibilities
that we've described,
one, where a particular read is
incompatible with an isoform,
two, where we had
a single end read
mapping to an isoform,
which is simply
1 over the length
of the isoform,
and three, where
we're mapping paired
end reads to an isoform,
which includes uncertainty
about where it will map,
which is the 1 over l sub j,
and also uncertainty about the
length of the fragment itself,
which is encoded in
the F function, which
is a distribution
over fragment lengths.
OK.
So once we have
this structure, we
can then estimate
isoform expression.
Now we talked before, when
we talked about ChIP-seq
last time, the idea of
estimating proportions.
And the essential idea
here is that if we
want to compute the
probability of a read given,
in this case, a mixture of
isoforms, that's simply going
to be-- let's see, what
variable did I use?
Yeah-- the estimated
concentration
of that isoform times the
probability of the read as
seen in that isoform.
So for an individual read, we
can estimate its likelihood
given this mixture.
And then the product
around the outside
describes how to
estimate the probability
of the entire basket of reads
that we see for that gene.
And what we would like to do
is to pick psi, in this case,
to maximize the likelihood
of the observed reads.
So what psi is
going to do is it's
going to give us the fraction
of each isoform that we see.
Are there any questions
about the idea
of isoform quantitation?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm a little lost in--
in the last full slide review,
you were describing these three
cases for excluded, single,
and paired reads.
So we're computing the
different probabilities
for both ends to happen in a
transcript, of for just one,
or--
PROFESSOR: It depends.
The second and third
cases depend upon
whether we're
analyzing single ended
reads or paired end reads.
And so we wouldn't use both
of them at the same time.
In other words, if you only
have single ended data,
you would use the second
case that we showed.
And if you had
paired end data, you
would use the third
case that we showed.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Question, yes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I noticed that the single
end reads case-- could you
explain the intuition behind
that probability [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
The intuition behind
that probability
is that we're asking--
so here is a transcript.
And we're assuming, what is
the probability of a read given
that it came from
this transcript.
OK?
What's the probability of
observing a particular read?
And the probability of
observing it lining up
at a particular position
is 1 over the length
of this transcript.
And so the probability actually
includes the idea of alignment
at a particular position
in the transcript.
OK?
So obviously, the
probability's 1
if we assume it comes from here
if we don't consider this fact.
But if we want to ask where
it lines up in the transcript,
it's going to be 1 over l sub j.
OK?
AUDIENCE: So we assume that
it's uniformly possible?
PROFESSOR: That it's
uniformly possible,
which gets us to a good point.
I'm glad you asked
that question.
Sometimes we would
have more reads
at the three prime end of
a transcript than the five
prime end.
Can anybody imagine why?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because you're
pulling on the poly-A tails.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this actually was
purified by the poly-A tail.
And we're pulling on this.
We're purifying by it.
And if there's breakage
of these transcripts
as it goes through the
biochemical processing,
we can get shorter
and shorter molecules.
They all contain this bit.
And the probability to contain
that whole thing actually
decreases.
So oftentimes there
is three prime bias
in RNA-seq experiments one
needs to be mindful of.
But we're assuming, today,
that there isn't such bias
and that the probability's
equal that it
maps someplace in
this transcript.
OK?
Does that answer your question?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I do have one more.
Can you show us how
that extends, then,
to the paired end read and where
the probability distribution--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if we go to paired end
reads, right, like this,
this component is going to
be where it aligns, right?
And then, the probability of the
length of this entire molecule
is what I had up
there before, which
is-- exactly how did I do that?
So this is going to be--
this is this bit, which
is the implied length of this.
OK?
So if I map the
left and the right--
this component is where
the left end maps.
OK?
I take the left and the
right ends of the read
that I have from
that transcript.
And it has a particular
length on this transcript.
OK?
I'll call that length
l sub j of R sub i.
Now remember, that
is not the same
as the length in the genome.
That's the length in this
transcript as it is spliced.
OK?
F is going to be the
probability distribution
of the length of the fragments.
So let's just say that they're
centered around 200 bases.
OK?
So if this is exactly 200 bases,
it's going to be quite likely.
OK?
But imagine that when
I map this fragment,
this wound up being
400 bases apart.
Then, this
distribution would tell
is it's very unlikely that
I would see a fragment that
mapped here and
mapped 400 bases up
here, because my fragment
with distribution defined by F
is 200 bases.
So it's going to discount
that, the probability of that.
So this term that the
probability of the read
given the transcript
is the component
of where it's aligning
times the likelihood
that the implied
fragment length agrees
with what we think
we have empirically.
OK?
Does that make sense?
OK.
Those are good questions.
So given this
framework, we can either
use EM or other machine learning
like frameworks to maximize psi
and to learn the
fraction of expression
of each different isoform
from the observed data given
the functions that we have.
And just to give
you an idea, when
this was done for
myogenesis, a program
called Cufflinks, which
does this kind of process
of identifying
isoform prevalences,
was able to identify a
large number of transcripts.
70% of the reads
were in previously
annotated transcripts.
But it also found 643
new isoforms of genes
in this single time series.
And I posted one
of the papers that
describes some this technology
on the Stellar site.
But note that certain of the
genes have light coverage.
And what we're seeing here is
that for genes are expressed
in low copy numbers,
it's obviously
more difficult to get
reads out of them.
And I'm presuming, in this
particular experiment--
although I can't recollect--
that the reason they don't see
that many intronic reads is
they did poly-A purification.
OK.
So we've talked about
how to take our reads,
build a probabilistic model,
estimate isoform prevalences.
And we know how many reads
are mapping to a given gene.
The question now
is whether or not
we see differential
expression of a gene
in different conditions.
So I'd like to turn to the
analysis of differential
expression unless there
are any final questions
about the details of RNA-seq
and isoform estimation.
This is your chance to
ask those hard questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I have a really silly question.
But can you explain, really
quickly, what are isoforms?
PROFESSOR: What an isoform is?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Sure.
An isoform is a particular
splice variant of a gene.
So a gene that has a
particular splicing pattern
is called an isoform.
So imagine we have three
exons, one, two, and three.
And a transcript that has all
three would be one isoform.
And another variant that omits
two would be a second isoform.
So just one in three
would be an isoform.
And each gene has a set
of isoforms it exhibits.
And that depends upon how it's
regulated and whether or not
any splicing is
constitutive-- it always
happens-- or whether
or not it's regulated.
And so in theory,
a gene with n exons
has how many potential isoforms?
It's 2 to the n.
Because you can consider each
exon being included or omitted.
All right.
But that isn't
typically the case--
that there are many
fewer isoforms than that.
But in general, an isoform
refers to a particular splice
variant of a gene.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I just want to
make sure I have everything
correctly.
When you're using single
legged or pair end reads,
you can get excluded
ends, right?
So you can get that in both
cases, whether or not you're--
PROFESSOR: Well, it depends.
Once again, it's
somewhat probabilistic
where the reads actually hit.
Because if all the
reads only hit exons,
and you didn't
get any junctions,
and none of your paired end
reads crossed junctions,
then you wouldn't
actually have exclusion.
All right?
AUDIENCE: But it's possible for
using both types of sequencing?
PROFESSOR: Yes, it's possible
with both types of sequencing.
In fact, oftentimes,
what people do
is that they will count
junction crossing reads.
If you have a large
enough number of reads
in your sequencing, say,
100 base pairs at least,
then a large number
of your reads
are going to be-- not a large,
but a significant fraction--
will be exon crossing.
And you'll be able to count the
number of exon-exon junctions
you have of different types.
And that will give
you an estimate
of how much splicing is going
on and will help validate
the kinds of conclusions
that come out of programs
like Cufflinks or MISO, which is
another program from the Burge
Laboratory that is used to
estimate isoform prevalence.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So even
given this information,
you can't say which exons go
with which exons necessarily,
except paralogs, right?
Because the reads, in
general, aren't long enough
to span an exon.
And therefore we wouldn't
know, for example,
that a given transcript is
exons one, five, and six.
You could only know that exons
five and six went together.
PROFESSOR: That is
not strictly true
if you have paired end
reads and your fragments
are long enough to span exons.
But in general, you're correct.
And that's why modern
sequencing technologies that
are coming down the pike
that can do 25 kilobase reads
are so important for doing
things just like that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In your diagram
of the read up there,
are the boxes the actual genome
or RNA sequence and the line
in between the artificial linker
that you added when you seq
ref'd?
PROFESSOR: Ah, that's
a good question.
The question is,
is this the linker
and these are the
actual sequences.
No.
What I'm drawing here is
that these are the bits
that we actually get
to see the sequence of.
We sequence from both
ends of a molecule.
This is the part of the fragment
that we haven't sequenced
because our reads
aren't long enough.
And so the entire fragment
might be 300 bases long.
If this is 100 and this is
100, then the unobserved part
is 100 in the middle.
OK?
And that's called
the insert length,
the entire length
of the molecule.
And we get to choose how
long these fragments are up
to a maximum size.
Contemporary
sequencers don't really
like fragments over 1,000 bases.
And the performance
starts falling off
when you get close
to that number.
So people, typically,
are operating
in a more optimal
range of fragments
that are a few
hundred bases long.
Any other questions?
OK.
So I wanted to briefly talk
about hypothesis testing.
Because we're going
to be needing it
for determining when things
are really differentially
expressed.
So I'm just going to
show you some data
and ask you a few
questions about it.
So here are two different
scatters of data.
Well, actually, it's
exactly the same data.
But we have two
different bits to it.
We have two
independent Gaussians
that are fit to the data,
from gene one and gene two.
And another fit
uses two Gaussians
that have a correlation
structure between them.
And the question
is whether or not
the null hypothesis or
the alternative hypothesis
is more reasonable.
And typically, when
we say reasonable,
we want to judge whether
or not it's significant.
Significance
typically talks about,
what's the chance
that the data we saw
occurred at random given
the null hypothesis.
So what's the chance
it was generated
by the null hypothesis
versus the chance
that it was generated by
the alternative hypothesis?
Now the problem is that
alternative hypotheses,
typically, are more complex.
And a more complex model will
always explain data better.
So we need to have
a principled way
of asking the question, given
that the alternative hypothesis
is always going to
do a better job,
does it do such a better
job that it can exclude
the null hypothesis at a
particular probability level.
OK?
So here are two different
models for these data.
The null model, H0,
is that they came
from two independent Gaussians.
The alternative model,
H1, is that they
came from two
correlated Gaussians.
And then we can
ask whether or not
H1 is sufficiently more likely
to warrant our rejecting H0
and accepting H1.
Now as I said, H1 is always
going to fit the data better.
So the probability
of that collection
of points evaluated with the
H1 model, fit to the data,
is always going to be superior.
So we need to have
a way to compare
the probability of the data
given H1 versus the data
given H0 in a way that
allows us to judge
the probability that the data
via H0 occurred at random.
In this particular case,
the data supports H1.
And let's see why.
So this is a key idea here.
How many people have heard of
likelihood ratio statistics
before?
OK.
About half the class.
So here's the idea.
The idea is that what
we're going to do
is we're going to
compute a test statistic.
And the test statistic
is going to be
a function of the observed data.
And it's 2 times the log of
the probability of the observed
data given H1 over the
probability of the observed
data given H0.
OK?
Now we know that
this is always going
to have a higher value than the
probability in the denominator.
So this is always going
to be greater than 1.
So the test statistic will
always be greater than 0
since we're operating
in the log domain.
OK?
The question is-- we
know that this is always
going to be better, even when
the data was generated from H0.
But when is this
sufficiently better
for us to believe that H0 is not
true and we should accept H1?
What we need is a distribution
for this test statistic
that occurred if H0 was true.
And that distribution allows
us to compute the probability
that an observed value
for the test statistic
occurred, even in the presence--
assuming that H0 is true.
OK.
So this depends upon
the number of degrees
of freedom difference
between H1 and H0.
How many degrees of
freedom are there
in H1 in this model up here?
How many parameters
do we get to pick?
AUDIENCE: Six.
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
PROFESSOR: Six?
AUDIENCE: Two means and four--
PROFESSOR: Two means
and four coherences.
And for H0?
AUDIENCE: Just four.
PROFESSOR: Four.
So what's the
difference in the number
of degrees of freedom
between H1 and H0?
It's two.
So the test statistic
is parametrized
by the difference in number
of degrees of freedom.
And so what we see, then, is
something that looks like this.
We see a test statistic where
this is the probability of it,
on the y-axis, and the test
statistic on the x-axis.
But as the test statistic
gets larger and larger,
the probability that it
occurred with H0 being true
gets smaller and smaller.
So let us just suppose that we
took our data from our model
that we observed.
And we computed the test
statistic at a particular value
call T observed.
So this is the actual
value that we computed out
of our likelihood ratio test.
What we would like to ask
is, what's the probability
that our test statistic is
greater than or equal to T
observed given that
H0 is true, which
means that we're
going to consider
all the tail of
this distribution.
Because we want to also consider
the case where T observed
was even greater
than what we saw.
And this gives us a way of
computing the probability
that H0 is true given
the test statistic.
And this gives us our p-value.
OK?
So this is a way of,
in general, comparing
two probabilistic models and
analyzing the significance
of adding extra degrees
of freedom to the model.
Typically, what we'll be
doing in today's lecture
is asking whether or
not-- if we let the means
change, for example,
between two conditions--
we get a sufficient
improvement in our ability
to predict the data that our
test statistic will allow
us to reject the null hypothesis
that the means are the same.
OK.
I'm going to stop
here and see if there
are any questions
at all about this.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Where did the degrees of
freedom enter into the equation?
PROFESSOR: Where did the degrees
of freedom enter into this?
Great question.
The chi-square tables
that you look up
are indexed by the
number of degrees
of freedom of difference.
OK?
And so whenever you
compute a chi-squared,
you will compute
it with the number
of degrees of
freedom difference.
Any other questions?
OK.
So let's now turn to evaluating
RNA-seq data once again.
And I'm going to describe
a method called DESeq
for determining
differential expression.
And in our analysis,
what we're going to do
is we're going to let i range
over a gene or an isoform.
j is an experiment.
And there may be
multiple experiments
in the same condition
that are replicates.
And Kij is the number of
counts observed for i and j.
So that's the expression of gene
or isoform i in experiment j.
Now what we need
to do, however, is
to normalize experiments
against one another.
And the normalization
factor s sub j
is computed for a
particular experiment.
And it's used to normalize
all of the values
in that experiment.
And if all the experiments
were completely identical--
the read depth was identical
and everything was the same--
then all of the s
sub js would be 1.
If you had an experiment that
had exactly twice as many reads
as the other experiments,
it's s sub j would be 2.
So this scale factor is
used to normalize things
in our next slide, as we'll see.
And the essential
idea is that we're
going to take the median
value of this ratio.
And the reason that the
denominator is a geometric mean
is so that no one experiment
dominates the average.
They all have equal
weight for the average.
But the geometric mean
is simply the product
of all of the expressions for
a particular median gene taken
to the root m power
to get them back
to the value for a
single experiment.
And that is the
normalizing factor
for the numerator, which
is the number of counts
for a particular gene.
OK?
So we're just doing
median style normalization
where s sub j is a scale factor.
Once again, if all the
experiments were the same,
s sub j would be 1.
If one particular experiment
had twice as many counts
as another experiment
uniformly, s
sub j would be 2, just
for that experiment.
Any questions about
the scale factor?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
what is the term
on the bottom-- in
the denominator?
PROFESSOR: That's
a normalizing term
across-- that's the geometric
mean of all the experiments put
together.
All right?
So because it's the product
of all the experiments-- m
experiments-- then,
rooted m, it's
equal to the geometric mean
of a single experiment.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are we normalizing
different experiments
to each other or
different replicates
of a single experiment?
PROFESSOR: In this particular
case, each one of these
is a different replicate.
OK?
So j is ranging over
different replicates,
not over conditions, right now.
So each replicate,
each experiment,
gets its own normalizing factor.
We'll see, in a moment, how to
put those replicates together
to build statistical strength.
But we need-- since each
replicate has its own read
depth, we have to normalize
each one independently.
OK?
So what we then do is we compute
an expression for a condition.
Now a condition,
we're going to call p.
And q sub ip is the
normalized expression
for gene slash isoform
i in condition p.
So a condition may have
multiple replicates in it.
So we're going to
average, over all
of the replicates, the
average expression,
as you can see here.
So we're summing over
all the replicates
for a given condition.
We're going to take
each replicate,
normalize it by its scale
factor we just computed,
and then compute the normalized
expression for a gene
or an isoform in that
particular condition.
Is that clear to everybody,
what's going on here?
Now I'm describing this to
you because the key fact is
the next line, which
is that we compute
the mean for a
particular replicate
by taking the normalized
expression for a gene
and then reverse correcting
it back to scaling it
back up again for that
particular replicate
by multiplying by s sub j.
But the most important
thing is what's
on the right hand side,
which is that the variance is
equal to the mean plus this
function of the expression.
And the reason this
is important is
that most other models for
modeling expression data
use Poisson models.
And we've already seen,
when we talked about library
complexity, that Poisson
models don't work that well
all the time.
So this is using a negative
binomial function, once again.
We saw negative
binomials before.
We're modelling both the
mean and the variance.
And the variance is a
function, a linear function
and a non-linear
function, of the mean.
So what's going to
happen, then, is
that we're going to use the
negative binomial to compute
the probability of observing
the data in a given condition.
And we can either combine
conditions and ask,
what's the probability of
seeing the conditions combined
with a single mean and variance,
or we can separate them
into a more complex
H1 hypothesis and ask,
what's the probability of
seeing them with separate means
and variances,
and then do a test
to see how significant the
difference is to determine
whether or not we can exclude
the fact that the genes are
expressed at the same level.
And to give you an intuitive
idea of what's going on,
this is a plot from the paper
showing the relationship
between mean expression
and variance.
Recall, for Poisson, that
variance is equal to mean.
We only have one parameter
to tune for Poisson,
which is lambda.
The purple line is Poisson.
And you can check and
see that the mean's
equal to the variance
in that case.
What DESeq does is it fits the
orange line to the observed
data.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I don't know where
the v sub p comes from.
Where is that, again?
PROFESSOR: That's the function.
V sub p, in that
equation up there,
is the function that
we're fitting-- that's
the solid orange
line-- to the observed
relationship between mean
and variance in the data.
OK?
So DESeq fits that function.
EdgeR is another technique that
does not fit and instead uses
the estimate that's the dotted
line, which isn't as good.
So a lot of people
use DESeq these days
for doing differential
expression analysis
because it allows the
variance to change
as the mean increases.
And this is the case for
these type of count data.
Before I go on though,
I'll pause and see
if there are any questions at
all about what's going on here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You said that mu sub
p, then, is the [INAUDIBLE]
to the data.
I'm confused.
How do we fit that function,
or where does that come from?
PROFESSOR: You
mean the mu sub p?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: That function is fit.
And the paper
describes exactly how
it's fit, which I posted
on the Stellar site.
But it's a nonlinear
function of q, in this case.
Good question.
Any other questions?
OK.
So once again, we
have two hypotheses,
the null hypothesis that A and
B are expressing identically,
H1, A and B
differentially express.
We can compute the number
of degrees of freedom.
And we can do a likelihood
ratio test, if we'd like,
to compute the
probability of H0.
And our model in this case is
the negative binomial model
of the data, which
fits the data better.
And that's why DESeq
does a better job
than other methodologies.
Because it provides a
better approximation
to the underlying noise.
And the next slide
shows what you get out
of this kind of analysis,
where the little red dots are
the genes that have
been called significant
using Benjamini-Hochberg
correction, which
we talked about previously.
And you can see how, as the mean
increases, the required log 2
fold change comes down
to be significant.
So oftentimes, you'll
see plots like this
in papers that describe how they
actually computed what genes
were differentially expressed.
Any questions at all?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is it
that the significance is
lower as the mean increases?
PROFESSOR: Why the
significance is lower?
AUDIENCE: Or the threshold.
PROFESSOR: Oh, because
as you increase
the number of observations,
the mean value theorem
is going to cause
things to actually get
closer and closer to 0.
And so you need less of
a fold change difference
to be significant as you get
more and more observations.
And other questions?
OK.
So now we're going to
delve into one other area.
How many people have done
hypergeometric tests before?
OK.
So we're going to talk
about hypergeometric tests.
So imagine that we have a
universe, for simplicity,
of 1,000 genes.
OK?
So we have this universe.
And we have, B is a set of
genes that there are 30 of them.
And there's another set,
A, of which there are 20.
And the overlap between these
two is a total of three genes.
So it might be that
A is the set of genes
that are differentially
expressed
between two conditions.
B is the set of genes
that, you happen to know,
have a particular annotation.
For example, they're involved
in stress response in the cell.
And you'd like to
know whether or not
the genes that are
differentially expressed
have a significant component of
stress response related genes
or whether or not this
occurred at random.
OK?
So we need to compute that.
So how many ways
could we choose B?
Well, if we are going to use--
this is n1, n2, this is big N,
and this is k.
All right?
So the number of ways I can
choose B is big N choose n2.
That's the number of ways I can
choose B. Is everybody with me
on that?
Yeah?
OK.
How many ways can I
choose three elements out
of A, these three that
are going to overlap?
Well, that's going
to be n1 choose k.
So that's how many ways I can
choose these three elements.
And then, how many ways could I
choose the other elements of B?
So once again, I'm figuring
out how I can choose B. Well,
how could I choose
the rest of B?
Well, how many elements do I
have to choose, of B, here?
Well, B is n too big.
But I've already
chosen k of them.
Right?
All right.
Sorry, it's the
other way around.
The universe I can
pick from is 1,000,
which is all the elements, minus
the elements of A that I've
already chosen from
to get those three.
And then I need to pick the
27 things they don't overlap
with A. So 27 things
that don't overlap with A
would be n2 minus k.
So this is the
number ways to choose
B given this set of constraints.
This is the number of ways to
choose B given no constraints.
So the probability
that I have overlap
of exactly k is equal
to this, which is,
how many ways are there
with no constraints
and how many ways
are there given
that I have an overlap of k.
All right?
And typically, what
I want to ask is,
what is the probability
that my observed overlap
is greater than or equal to k.
So this case, the
overlap would be three.
But I also would need
to consider the fact
that I might have four,
or five, or six, which
would be even more unlikely,
but still significant.
So if you look at the
exact computation,
the probability of
three here is 0.017.
And the probability that I
have three or more is 0.02.
So that's still
pretty significant.
Unlikely that would
occur by chance.
Right?
That I have three or more genes
overlapping in this situation
could only happen
two out of 100 times.
Does everybody understand
what's going on here?
Any questions at all?
So you're all now
hypergeometric whizzes, right?
All right?
Fantastic.
OK.
Now we're going to turn to
a final kind of analysis.
How many people have heard of
principal component analysis
before?
How many people know how to do
principal component analysis?
A few.
OK.
Great.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
could you just briefly
mention, again, where exactly do
we use the hypergeometric test?
What kinds of questions are
we asking when we do that?
PROFESSOR: Typically,
they're overlap questions.
So you're asking-- you have a
universe of objects, right--
like, in this case, genes.
And you have a subset of
20 and a subset of 30.
Let's say these are the
differentially expressed genes.
These are genes in the
stress response pathway.
They overlap by three genes.
Does that actually
occur at random or not?
All right?
If I told you that there are
a much smaller number of genes
and the stress response
genes were very much larger,
it could be much easier for
that overlap to occur at random.
Good question.
Any other questions?
OK.
So the next part of
lecture is entitled
"multivariate Gaussians
are your friends."
OK?
They are friendly.
They're like a puppy dog.
They are just wonderful to
play with and very friendly.
And the reason most people get
a little turned off by them
is because they get this--
the first thing they're shown
is this very hairy
looking exponential
which describes what they are.
And so I'm going to shy away
from complicated looking
exponentials and give you the
puppy dog, my favorite way
of looking at
multivariate Gaussians.
OK?
Which, I think, is a
great way to look at them.
And the reason we need to
look at multivariate Gaussians
is that they help
us understand what
is going on with principal
component analysis in a very
straightforward way.
And the reason that we want
to use principal component
analysis is that
we're going to be
able to reveal hidden factors
and structures in our data.
And they're also
going to allow us
to reduce the
dimensionality of the data.
And we'll see why in a moment.
But here is the friendly version
of multivariate Gaussians.
And let me describe to you why
I think this is so friendly.
So we're all familiar with
unidimensional Gaussians
like this.
Centered at zero.
They have variance 1.
Just very friendly
univariate Gaussians, right?
Everybody's familiar with those?
Normal distributions?
So let's suppose
that we just take
a whole collection of those.
And we say that we
have a vector z that
is sampled from a collection
of univariate Gaussians.
And it can be as
long as we like.
OK?
But they're all sampled
from the same distribution.
And what we're going to say is
that our multivariate Gaussian,
x, is going to be a matrix
times z plus a mean.
And so what this
matrix is going to do
is it's going to take all
of our univariate Gaussians
and combine them to produce
our multivariate Gaussian.
All right?
So the structure
of this matrix will
describe how these single
variate Gaussians are
being mixed together to produce
this multivariate distribution.
And you can imagine
various structures
for this matrix A. Right?
And the covariance
matrix, sigma,
which describes the structure
of this multivariate Gaussian,
is shown on this slide to
be equal to A A transpose.
And thus, if we knew this
matrix A, which we may not know,
we'd be able to compute the
covariance matrix directly.
OK?
Let me take that one more time.
We take a bunch of
univariate Gaussians,
make a vector z out of them.
And just for
clarity, right, we're
going to talk about matrices and
vectors as rows across columns.
So this is n by 1.
This is n by n.
This is n by 1.
And this is n by 1.
OK?
That's the dimensionality
of these various objects
we're dealing with here.
So we get this vector
of univariate Gaussians.
We apply this matrix n
to combine them together.
We get out our multivariate
Gaussian offset by some mean.
Is everybody happy
with that so far?
Yes?
No?
You're suspending disbelief
for the next slide.
Is that-- OK.
Well, here's the next
thing I'd like to say,
is that the variance of
a vector-- we'll call it
v-- times x, which
is a random variable,
is going to be equal
to-- x is derived
from this distribution--
v transpose sigma
v. And the demonstration of
that is on the top of this page.
So the variance of this
vector-- sorry, the projection
of this random variable
onto this vector--
is going to give you a
variance in this direction
as that product.
So what we would
like to do is this.
We would like to find v
sub i, which are vectors,
to maximize variance
of v sub i transpose x
such that v sub i transpose
v sub i is equal to 1.
In other words, they're
unit length vectors.
So these are going to be
called the eigenvectors.
And if we think about the
structure that we desire,
what we'll find is that
they satisfy the constraint
that the covariance matrix
times an eigenvector
is equal to the
eigenvalue associated
with that vector times
the vector itself.
And with a little manipulation--
if we multiply both sides by v
sub i transpose-- v sub i equals
v sub i transpose lambda sub i
sigma squared v sub i-- and
we move these guys around,
v sub i transpose
sigma v sub i is
equal to-- these two
guys, multiplied together,
equal 1-- lambda sub i squared.
This, we see up above,
is equal to the variance
when it's projected
in the direction of v.
And so lambda sub i squared is
simply the variance associated
with that direction.
So the question then becomes,
how do we find these things.
And how do we discover
these magic eigenvectors
that are directions in which
this multivariate Gaussian has
its variance maximized?
And we can do this by
singular value decomposition.
So we can compute this
covariance matrix.
So we compute sigma
from the data.
And then we do a singular
value decomposition
such that sigma is equal
to U S U transpose.
And that's what the singular
value decomposition does
for us is it
decomposes the sigma
matrix into these
components where
S is a diagonal matrix that
contains the eigenvalues
and U is a column.
Each column is an eigenvector.
So in doing a singular
value decomposition,
we get the eigenvalues
and the eigenvectors.
The other thing, you
recall, was that sigma
was equal to A A transpose
when we started off.
A was the matrix that we used to
make our multivariate Gaussian
out of our univariate Gaussians.
And thus, what we can observe is
that our multivariate Gaussian
x is equal to U S to the
1/2 times z plus a mean.
So here is what's going when we
make a multivariate Gaussian is
we're taking a bunch of
univariate Gaussians,
we're scaling them, and
we're rotating them.
OK?
And that makes a
multivariate Gaussian.
And then we offset this
whole thing by a mean.
Because we also have to do
rotations around the origin.
So the way I think about
multivariate Gaussians
is that it is a
scaling and a rotation
of univariate Gaussians.
And implicit in that
scaling and rotation
is the discovery of the
major directions of variance
in the underlying
data as represented
by the eigenvectors.
And the eigenvalues tell
you how much of the variance
is accounted for in each
one of those dimensions.
Are there any
questions about that?
I hope there are.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do you
compute sigma from the data?
Is it some magical process?
PROFESSOR: The sigma of
the value of decomposition?
AUDIENCE: No.
So--
PROFESSOR: How do you
compute sigma from the data?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the first step.
PROFESSOR: That is
shown in equation seven.
So you can compute the means.
And you know you have x,
which are observed values.
So you compute that expectation.
And that is sigma.
OK?
Good question.
Any other questions?
OK.
So we have these
eigenvectors and eigenvalues,
which represent the
vectors of maximum variance
in the underlying data.
And we can use these to organize
data by projecting observations
onto these eigenvectors--
or they're sometimes
called principal components--
defined dimensions
of variability that help us
organize our underlying data.
We'll come back to
that in a moment.
OK.
Any other questions about
principal component analysis?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
e was expectation
when you were
calculating the second?
PROFESSOR: Yes, e is the
expectation is correct.
AUDIENCE: And also
what that means.
PROFESSOR: It's the
average expected value.
So in the case of
computing sigma,
you would compute the expected
value of that inner equation
across all the data
points that you see.
So you'd sum up all
the values and divide
by the number of
things that you had.
Any other questions?
OK.
So just for calibration for
next year, how many people
think they've got a general
idea of what principal component
analysis is-- a general idea?
Uh-oh.
How many people who thought
it was really interesting
were sort of completely
baffled about halfway through?
OK.
All right.
Well, I think that
recitation can
help with some of
those questions.
But if anybody has a question
they'd like to ask now-- No?
It's that far gone?
I mean, the thing with
this sort of analysis
is that if your matrix algebra
is a little rusty, then,
when you start looking
at equations like that,
you can get a little
lost sometimes.
All right.
Well, let's turn, then-- if
there aren't any brave souls
who wish to ask
a question, we'll
turn to single cell
RNA-seq analysis.
So I'm a firm believer
that single cell analysis
of biological samples is
the next big frontier.
And it's being made possible
through devices like this.
This is a Fluidigm C1 chip,
which has 96 different reaction
wells, which allows
you, in each well,
to process a single
cell independently.
And the little winds are ways
to get reagents into those cells
to do things like produce
RNA-seq ready materials.
And when you do
single cell analysis,
you can take apart what's
happening in a population.
So an early paper asked some
fairly fundamental but simple
questions.
For example, if you take
two 10,000 cell aliquots
of the same culture, and you
profile them independently,
and you ask how well to the
expression values for each gene
agree between sample
A and sample B,
you expect there to be a very
good agreement between sample A
and sample B in these
10,000 cell cultures.
A second question is, now,
if you take, say, 14 cells
from those cultures and you
profile them independently,
and you ask, how well
do they correlate
with what you saw in the
10,000 cell experiment, that
will tell you something about
the population heterogeneity
that you're observing.
Because if they correlate
perfectly with the 10,000 cell
experiment, then you
really know that there's
no point in looking at
individual cells in some sense,
because they're all the same.
Seen one, seem them all.
Right?
But if you find
that each cell has
its own particular
expression fingerprint
and what you're seeing in the
10,000 cell average experiment
wipes out those
fingerprints, then you
know it's very important to
analyze each cell individually.
So the analysis that was done
asked exactly that question.
So here's what I'll
show you in these plots.
So here is, on the upper left,
the 10,000 cell experiment
versus the 10,000
cell experiment.
And as you can see, the
correlation coefficient
is quite high-- 0.98--
and looks very, very good
of experiment one
versus experiment two,
or rep one, rep two.
Here is a separate
experiment which
is looking at two
individual cells
and asking-- and
plotting, for each gene,
the expression in one
cell versus the gene
in the other cell.
And you can see that the
correlation coefficient's 0.54.
And there's actually
a fairly wide spread.
In fact, there are genes that
are expressed in one cell that
are not expressed in the
other cell, and vice versa.
So the expression of
these individual cells
it's quite divergent.
And the final panel
shows how-- down here--
how a single cell
average on the y-axis
relates to the 10,000
cell experiment.
But given the middle
panel-- the panel B there--
that is showing the fact that
two single cells don't really
relate that well to another,
it bags other questions.
For example, are the
isoforms of the genes that
are being expressed the same
in those distinct cells?
And so panel D
shows isoforms that
are the same across each one
of the single cells being
profiled, which is the
solid bar at the top.
And the bottom couple
of rows in figure D
are the 10,000 cell
experiment average.
But panel E is the
most interesting,
perhaps, which is that the
isoforms for those four genes
are being
differentially expressed
in different individual cells.
And that's further supported
by taking two of those genes
and doing fluorescent in situ
histochemistry and microscopy,
and looking at the
number of RNA molecules
for each one of those, and
noting that it corresponds
to what's seen in the
upper right hand panel.
So we see that in
individual cells,
different isoforms
are being expressed.
Now these cells were
derived from bone marrow.
And they're exposed
to lipopolysaccharide
to activate an immune response.
So they are clearly not all
behaving exactly the same.
And to further elucidate this,
the authors of this paper
took the gene
expressions that they
saw for a given cell
as a large vector
and computed the
principal components,
and then projected the cells
into the first and second
principal component
or eigenvector space.
And as you can see, there is
a distinct separation of three
of the cells from the
rest of the cells, where
three of the cells,
which correlate well
with principal component
one, are thought
to be mature cells that
express certain cell surface
proteins whereas the ones
on the left-- the maturing
cells-- the triangle
depicted cells--
express certain cytokines
under the maturing legend
there, on the clustergram
on the right-hand side.
And thus, the first
principal component
was able to separate those
two different broad classes
of cells.
So it looks like there are
at least two different kinds
of cells in this population.
And then, the authors
asked another question,
which is, can they take
individual cell data
and look at the relationship
between pairs of genes
to see which genes
are co-expressed.
And the hypothesis
is that genes that
are co-expressed
in individual cells
make up individual
regulatory circuits.
And so they hypothesize that
the genes LRF7 and IFIT1
and STAT2 and LRF7 are all in an
anti-viral regulatory circuit.
They then ask the question,
if they knocked out
LRF7, which is the second
panel on the right-hand side,
would they oblate
downstream gene expression.
And they partially did.
And they thought that since
STAT2 and LRF7 are both thought
to be regulators of
the circuit and they're
both downstream of the
interfering receptor,
they thought if they knocked
out the interfering receptor,
they would oblate most of
the anti-viral cluster,
which, in fact, they did.
So what this is suggesting
is that, first, single cell
analysis is
extraordinarily important
to understand what's going
on in individual cells.
Because in a cell culture, the
cells can be quite different.
And secondarily, it's
possible, within the context
of individual single
cell analysis,
to be able to pick out
regulatory circuits that
wouldn't be as
evident when you're
looking at cells en masse.
And finally-- I'll thank Mike
for the next two slides--
I wanted to point
out that quality
metrics for RNA-seq data for
single cells is very important.
And we talked about library
complexity earlier in the term.
And here, you can see that as
library complexity increases,
expression of coefficient
of variation, which
is the standard
deviation over the mean,
comes down as you get
sufficient library complexity.
And furthermore, as library
complexity increases,
mean expression increases.
And the cells that are in
red were classified as bad
by microscopy, from the Fluidigm
instrument processing step.
So I think you can see that
single cell analysis is going
to be extraordinarily
important and can reveal
a lot of information that is
not present in these large batch
experiments.
And it's coming
to a lab near you.
So on that note, I'll thank
you very much for today.
And we'll see you
later in the term.
And Professor Burge will
return at the next lecture.
Thanks very much.